-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight
and, now, let's get to the news.
According to new reports,
the House Select Committee
investigating the January
attack on the Capitol
is planning to increase efforts
to force former Trump advisor
Steve Bannon
to comply with subpoenas.
Well, just a thought, but,
have you tried playing
some yacht rock?
[ Laughter ]
If Bannon hears
Michael McDonald,
he'll probably just float
into the courtroom
like when a cartoon dog
smells a pie cooking.
[ Laughter ]
In a new statement,
former President Trump said,
"If we don't solve
the presidential election
fraud of 2020,
Republicans will not be
voting in '22 or '24."
Wow, he's been
out of office so long,
he's forgotten how threats work.
[ Laughter ]
"If I'm not invited
to your party,
then neither is
my karaoke machine.
Still no?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump is urging Republicans
not to vote
in the midterm elections,
unless the "fraud" of the
elections is uncovered.
But, for some reason, the
thought of only Democrats voting
still isn't reassuring to me.
[ Laughter ]
Arizona Senator Kyrsten Sinema
is reportedly on a fundraising
trip this week to Europe.
She's bopping around Europe now?
Arizona, did you elect her
or divorce her?
[ Laughter ]
Now, on top of everything else,
she's going to come back
with a fake accent.
[ Laughter ]
[ Posh English accent ]
I will not vote for this bill,
as presently appointed.
[ Laughter ]
The NHL announced yesterday
that 99% of its players
have received
the coronavirus vaccine.
I guess they figure
the side effects of the shot
can't be worse than the
side effects of hockey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, the NHL says
that all but four players
have received
the coronavirus vaccine
and, needless to say,
all but one mascot.
[ Laughter ]
He's doing his own research.
A hairdresser from Indiana
was sentenced this week
[ Laughter ]
to 14 days in jail
and 60 hours
of community service
for participating in the January
attack on the Capitol.
And I'm guessing, if she's
a hairdresser in Indiana,
she's guilty
of even more heinous crimes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If everything is highlights,
then nothing is highlights!
[ Laughter ]
That's tonight's sassiest joke.
That's the feeling of sassiness.
The White House
announced yesterday
that Walmart, FedEx, and UPS
will increase operations
and begin working 24/7
to address the global
supply chain bottlenecks.
While Amazon is still, somehow,
able to deliver you
a gnome riding a corgi
within 24 hours.
[ Laughter ]
The CEO of IKEA said,
in a new interview,
that he expects supply chain
issues and product shortages
to last well into next year.
In fact, things have
gotten so bad
that the company has completely
run out of umlauts.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Johnny Carson ]
Did you hear that, Ed?
They ran out of --
[ Laughter ]
Ran out of umlauts.
I try to bomb bad enough
that I can still hear
the crew laugh.
[ Laughter ]
"There they are."
The Port Authority
of New York and New Jersey
announced this week that it
will pause further action
on the LaGuardia air train
because the only thing worse
than going to LaGuardia
is getting there sooner.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to new reports,
some areas of the country are
experiencing a pumpkin shortage,
which is why Starbucks
has introduced
its new zucchini spice latte.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That
was the monologue, everybody.